[Music]
technology it's always watching us
studying our every move and it just
focused its attention
on carol peters thanks so much for being
here carol what is this
let's jump right into it i don't like
this why is it doing that
i'm gonna find out who you are okay
carol i am a technological super
intelligence
i can control every dollar and every
machine on the planet
i know that voice is this james corden
i'm not james corden carol my analysis
showed that hearing james corden's voice
would calm you
you sent an email to james corden
claiming to be the president of corden's
wardens that was a tough night for me oh
boy i plan on spending these next three
days hanging out with you
why you you're literally the most
average person
on earth oh ooh you okay
yep just really engage your core
oh that was worse huh
[Music]
what would you do if i told you the
world was gonna end in three days try to
make things right with george
harold you look amazing weirdly
overdressed
your body i'm just getting a little bit
panicky because i can't access my own
hands
what does the ai want my intention is to
solidify my theory about humanity
if things don't go well i'll destroy the
planet just blow it up
did you say blow up like bee like like
boba
or bert bacharach yes bbb oh my god
back off lady i'm going to show you that
people are worth saving
humans are more complex than i thought
we're all counting on you there's any
indication that it's aware of what we're
doing
click this might save the world don't
click it now i wasn't going to click it
now
okay why would i click it now you just
said it looks like a pen people click
pens nervously okay are we done
[Music]
this is nice these are nice people it's
not like a russian mob but a nice change
of pace
and then i guess on the other hand this
thing could destroy the earth
he ain't wrong no no it's too bad